yeah he's just like a hero amongst us
well that's eaten in new orleans man i
mean orange is [ __ ] crazy bro
it's crazy i spent a lot of time there
i'm not welcome back i don't think but
and what happened you get an argument
with somebody about a recipe no i got in
a fight about uh
i got enough football argument online
and uh and that was people got
a little upset at me was that after the
minnesota miracle or not
or before it um it was after the
minnesota miracle or no no it was after
the saints
uh that call where they got robbed that
pass interference no call
yeah and i made some side comment
and um you got a question about it it's
semi-related to uh getting in tiffs
about sports
okay disgusting okay
living in those what up theo what up
nick gang gang
what up uh i got a question i basically
got this guy
and a [ __ ] broken cheek for wearing a
pittsburgh pirate hat reppin them
stillers
pittsburgh you know i mean but my
question is
nick i know you talk a lot of [ __ ] about
the
minnesota sports when you're
rollerblading down reno yeah living in
those randy moss culpepper days but uh
my question is have you ever been hit or
someone try to fight you for
talking [ __ ] about sports or something
and same for you theo what about them
saints
yeah oh and by the way i don't live here
this is where i work
just to clarify because i know it looks
like [ __ ]
no man it looks fine dude i'm sorry
what's happening all right yeah turning
into a black guy it looks like
dude that's yeah yeah that dude right
there yeah that was that was the shiner
dude
yeah that was a [ __ ] pop um i have
other questions about that was it a
sucker punch or was it [ __ ] face to
face
where this dude came in stealth that
looks like sucker punch
that looks like that's a black that
looks like i've ever seen pittsburgh
haymaker
guy dodged it came back
that punxsutawney phil hit him with that
[ __ ] surprise gopher dude
don flamingo
um to answer your question i have i
being from minnesota were a little bit
more docile
very docile so um i i don't really get
in fisticuffs
um when i'm out about i don't really
talk [ __ ]
and i know it sounds like a [ __ ] move
in person yeah
i mean like i'll talk [ __ ] and then i'll
be like okay i'll buy you a beer you
know what i mean
i mean not to say that you know fighting
is just i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
into that [ __ ] because i'm on camera
this is the [ __ ]
the brad pitt right here oh yeah of fart
jokes
yeah no but i i just it's not at that
point like worth it where i'm gonna go
into blows you know i mean i like just
popping off but it's like you know what
i mean minnesota we don't like
escalate it that much now what state
does escalated i think
every other one yeah every other state
you know i'll say this dude minnesota is
the one place where i feel like i have
the toughest time with audiences there
they're just
they almost don't want to engage too
much they're almost just being nice in a
lot of ways like
like they're loving the show i feel like
but they just
sometimes they don't want to go too
outside with their with imaginations
because it's just
i don't know they kind of just stay in
some zones i feel like it depends upon
the crowd that you get but
for the most part they're they're always
with you they're good crowds
they get it um you can kind of challenge
them i mean i'm not
my comedy is always just me but like
other comics that like really
push it they've always done well like
doug stanhope always has a great fan
base and following there and you know he
pushes his audience i've seen it for
since i started you know for 20 plus
years yeah and you know there's certain
comics where that's their thing and
you know minnesota crowds like they they
welcome that stuff i mean it does
push like certain people you can tell
they're like oh all right
that was a warning yeah that was a one
okay mister
yeah no more snickerdoodles for you
bucko
how are you take all right but uh yeah
so to answer your question i haven't
really gotten into like blows and stuff
but i mean
i did go to an eagles game and uh there
were a couple games i've gone to where i
was like
i mean i went to an eagles game with
like a bunch of my buddies from philly
but like not that like that matters
yeah but i did see uh i go to eagle
stadium for the first time i
i can't remember what it's called but
what was to say eagles saying you know
what i'm talking about the nest i think
they call it
yeah and so i go
and i walk in and i see this philly
eagles fan
lincoln field mm-hmm and a little slam
pizza
this guy's at the field his hat's like
this he's probably
30 but he looks like he's 50. and his
hat's like he's got a cigarette in the
stadium it might be david akers
it might be david hankers dude so he's
chewing out there's this
nice ram they're playing the rams not a
rival
this is early in the season this guy's
in this dude's face
in a rams jersey the guy polite quiet
and this guy's like
[ __ ] rams we'll [ __ ] eat you for
[ __ ] breakfast
[ __ ] lunch just in this dude's grill
and this guy is just
polite just taking it and this that's
the first thing i saw and i was like
here we go yeah and you know i don't
know it was pretty interesting
do you think that they are because i
remember i went to philly one night
there's the first time i went to a place
called manion and i ended up in an attic
somebody said it was a nightclub it was
just some guy's attic you know who had
some [ __ ] hot electronics
right and every between every song of
nelly that they would play
they uh would play the philadelphia
eagles fight song
and then like they kept saying who wants
to [ __ ] these slam pigs and it was like
some kind of
you know reuben s type of young you know
women you know
right of age women legal women but who
were trying to just do sex with
everybody and
it was extremely alarming to me man i
felt very scared and this was supposed
to be at a fun at a night time at a
nightclub you know
right uh philly is a conundrum i have
great shows there my fan base there is
awesome everybody's so cool
yeah been great to me but it is one of
those places where like i
you gotta just know and go out with
people yeah i mean i've had
friends in from philly out in philly and
this is my favorite thing
and i don't know many places like this
where they're like i'll be like yeah
what's up they're like hey nick what's
going on right now we'll do a shot
what's [ __ ] [ __ ] and be like my buddies
from philly
like we'll part of philly and if you're
from like
some other part that's like right
outside yeah or maybe outside but not in
part of
like and they'll be like what are you
fighting off this [ __ ] guy
yeah like i want to do a show in philly
just called this [ __ ] guy
because all my friends from philly
anytime somebody says something that
they don't like or approve they're like
this is [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy here
with his [ __ ] with his [ __ ] pants
you're not from philly like minnesota
you could be like i'm from the
border and a [ __ ] under a lake five
hours outside of minnesota
yeah and they'd be like oh yeah yeah i
know where that is yeah
i'm really like the [ __ ] are you from a
block away i know that [ __ ] black the
[ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] out of here you [ __ ] leper this
[ __ ] leper
yeah everybody yeah philly everybody's
mother has a [ __ ] neck tat
everybody's
you know got a neck brace that's a new
hot thing on a lot of these
chicks out there the [ __ ] sexy you
know the neck race with the leopard
print you know
the leopard um race dude i'll say this
about philly man
uh if you go up by broad street by
temple university yeah
it gets a little dicey okay
yeah i saw a bird up there [ __ ]
selling coke one time dude i'm not even
joking they had a
crow and it had a little bag of [ __ ]
rocks hooked to its own
i know i've seen that dude i was [ __ ]
in philly one time and i saw cops
surrounding a bird house and it was a
bird crack house
and they had guns drawn and everything
dude there was [ __ ] five birds in
there
just flipping yay dude just making it
[ __ ] rain
yeah but phil i mean i like philly i
have a blast i mean
i go out and [ __ ] drank dude yeah
like new orleans i love i was bummed
because people got mad at me
but i it's funny because i sided with
that call so i like made some joke about
like yeah okay
vikings blah blah and then people like
[ __ ] you and
they're like you better not come back
new orleans yeah no one's oh
i was like whatever bro i [ __ ] go to
new orleans i love it and i agreed with
the call
states got [ __ ] robbed i'm a sports
fan like i'm logical
like when i see something i'm like okay
if somebody wins and they play good
i give it up i'm not one of those
[ __ ] delusional [ __ ]
loons yeah that's just blind and just
like nope
[ __ ] you i'm like no you guys got robbed
the saints got rod that was
that's one of the most insane no calls
i've ever seen in my life yeah good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one